welcome to the Daily I'm Neil Patterson
and today we return to us politics our
favorite topic of mine something I
really never get tired of discussing in
fact but on this occasion even I'm
experiencing a bit of deja vu
well I ran for president four years ago
I said we're in a battle for the soul of
America and we still are
the question we're facing is whether in
the years ahead we have more freedom or
less freedom
more rights are fewer
I know what I want the answer to be and
I think you do too
this is not a time to be complex
[Music]
that's why I'm running for re-election
I know America
that of course President Joe Biden and
I'm saying that he wants to have a
second time in the Oval Office
against the backdrop of some pretty poor
approval ratings Biden isn't necessarily
the first choice of every Democratic
strategist but some impressive results
in the midterms mean there really isn't
another clear candidate yet he is
already the oldest president in U.S
history and if he gains that second term
he will be get this 86 when he finally
leaves office and presumably has a sit
down for a while the expectation is that
he will be facing the guy he beat in
2020 the second oldest man to ever sit
in the Oval Office Donald Trump in order
to make America great and glorious again
I am tonight announcing my candidacy for
president of the United States
at a sprightly 76 Trump beat Biden to
the punch announcing his candidacy in
November last year since then however he
has become the first former or current
president to be charged with a crime 34
felony counts in fact a falsifying
business records and conspiracy to which
he has pleaded not guilty yet who would
bet against him facing off against Biden
next November in a very real sense here
we go again
later I'll be speaking to two
strategists from opposite sides of the
American political divide but first our
U.S correspondent Mark Stone months and
months ago now my colleague and I Emily
Purser our bureau chief here she and I
had a bet she said of course he'll run
again and I said I'm not so sure he will
actually there was this idea that he'd
be a one-term president that he'd hand
on to someone else and I assumed that
those closest to him his family his wife
the first lady Jill Biden might just
counsel him that actually you know what
pop you know what Joe you've had a great
first run
um you had a great four years as they
would see it
um let's find a really good successor
and hand on to them he's he's not he's
not getting any younger let's be honest
that's the core concern it's the attack
point from the right and it is a genuine
worry from the left and and the center
left obviously I was wrong because Joe
Biden is a man who has lived and
breathed politics for so many decades
the one of the youngest Senators on
Capital Hill he's always wanted to be
president and why on Earth would he give
it up after just one term and that was
my colleague's cold Logic the cold logic
of Politics the starting point from
which Joe Biden at launches his bid for
a second term it ain't great is it I
mean you look at the personal approval
ratings they're not fantastic he's kind
of below the water line as they say
below 50 way below I mean in the high
30s in terms of his approval rating and
then this really interesting poll done
at the weekend by NBC News
um our colleagues there released a poll
which suggested that only one in four
Americans would like to see Joe Biden
run again and that obviously includes
Democrats includes people who voted for
him last time they just don't want him
back incidentally the same poll suggests
that pretty much the same number 30 or
so want um Donald Trump to run so we've
got these two elderly men and I think
that is a legitimate point to bring up
their age who are going to rerun 2020.
it's all gonna happen again all very
divided but fascinating stuff presumably
though there is a calculation in the
white house that looks at what went on
in 2020 and thinks well you know what
why not that's the central calculation I
think in the white house it's kind of
simple but but risky logic and it is
that Trump was was beaten by Biden three
and a half years ago therefore Biden can
do it again truly on the part of the
American elector at the first place day
Luke went electing a president
particularly electing one who is you're
choosing someone who is the incumbent is
on the successes or otherwise of the
first term and in terms of his
achievements why are they I was at an
event in Washington uh that was
effectively the collective trades unions
of Builders across the United States so
blue collar workers as they're known
whether they be bricklayers whether they
be plumbers um anything to do with
infrastructure and building thousands of
them gathered into the Washington Hilton
and the guest of honor was Joe Biden is
that the strongest economy in the world
we need the best infrastructure in the
world
there were multiple standing ovations
for him this was his uh his natural
habitat and these are the people who
will vote for him next time because of
one of his key achievements passing
what's known as the infrastructure bill
um spending millions and millions and
millions of dollars rebuilding America
these are the people who are
traditionally Democrats who in 2016
decided they'd give Trump a shot and so
he is trying to win them back
I'm happy that he's running again it's
better than that orange thing
but a lot of these old Rust Belt towns
Want Steal towns but no longer they are
still really suffering so it's not
straightforward it's not clear-cut so
infrastructure and the economy inflation
aside is doing pretty well under Biden
but the pain of inflation is so extreme
that a lot of people won't feel
um any successes that the economy has
got I mean you know unemployment is at
record lows but in place you know it's
so expensive to buy a pint of milk at
seven eight dollars that that people
will not necessarily appreciate any any
of the sort of core uh strengths of the
of the American economy I think
Democrats Neil would see that over the
course of the past three and a half
years Biden has done what he wanted to
do which is sort of restore the soul of
the nation uh steady the tiller after
after such chaos of the Trump years as
the Democrats would see it in his
campaign video he's almost kind of
projecting himself as a father figure a
father of the nation that's the sort of
image he's going for calm the voice was
low and I just felt that he was trying
to juxtapose calm steady Authority
experience 80 yes it's old but it also
means he's massively experienced he's
juxtaposing that against the chaos of
Donald Trump even in the achievements
that you have listed it is questionable
whether or not the American electorate
is is noticing and saw recent poll in
the Washington Post 62 think that Joe
Biden has accomplished not very much or
or little or nothing so so there's a
problem certainly in in terms of
communications but if you want an
example of a failure of Joe Biden surely
we go straight back to the first day
that he entered the White House and he
said that he would unite America I mean
that clearly hasn't happened people
don't believe uh broadly that he has
been a particularly successful president
but
it goes back to a phrase that Biden has
used so many times don't compare me to
the almighty compare me to the
alternative I mean that is really hardly
an inspirational he's basically saying
I'm not as bad as the other one it's not
a great assessment of the of where
America is that no one younger or more
Dynamic with the same you know political
agenda whether it be left or right has
has emerged but I think the Judgment
that they were making in the Trump White
House is that Biden Harris beat Trump
last time Trump's going to be the
contender they're going to need to put
that team forward because no one else
has emerged to try to beat him again and
don't forget I mean you know look at
look back at history and I think I think
it was 95 Clinton was going for his
second term he was not the choice of
many for the Democratic candidate for a
second term even you know he obviously
wanted a second term but a lot of people
didn't want him and yet as as that year
turned into the election year um they
all fell behind him him and they voted
for him I thought the whole plan was Joe
Biden comes in has his term gets his
obtain in the Oval Office and then
Kamala Harris would go for it the next
time around I mean clearly that's not
going to happen she's she's clearly not
up to muster she has been a real
disappointment for many she hasn't
punched through in a way that people
imagined she would there was such
excitement over the first female vice
president the first black vice president
I mean it was an amazing moment that
have also over the course of the past
few years been suggestions that that she
and and Joe Biden haven't always seen
eye to eye that they haven't got on
they've never been stood up the old gray
wrinkly elephant in the room of of Joe
Biden's age when he is up against
someone in Donald Trump or we're
Assuming he's up against someone in
Donald Trump who himself is no spring
chicken Donald Trump sometimes he seems
more agile the debate between Biden and
Trump even when it happens
um this time around will be electrifying
um and you know it'll be maybe pretty
cringing at times because look honestly
I've been looking at some of Biden's
speeches that he gave four or five years
ago and comparing them with speeches
he's given recently and he has aged he
is less fluent that's not a jibe it's
it's it's a it's an observation he is
older uh four years older and that shows
shooting at Donald Trump's time in the
White House Washington Post they kept a
record of every lie that had been told
at Fox News however during the Biden uh
presidency are are keeping a record of
every time he makes a gaffe that he
makes a misstatement that he calls
someone by the wrong name does that not
at least show that in the minds of a
significant chunk of the American
electorate Joe Biden's age is not just a
passing concern it is an active concern
for a lot of people yeah and it's got
him into trouble uh not his age but his
gaffs whether the two are related is is
debatable so there have been moments
where his lack of fluency could cause
genuine problems and obviously for for
Republicans that's a a central attack
point and so it should be
foreign
things up you were a senator and you're
the worst president America has ever had
it would be difficult to imagine a more
acrimonious election than Trump versus
Biden back in 2020 and as for the idea
that's come 2024 both men will be older
and wiser well I suppose one out of two
isn't bad
but how best to fight that campaign to
keep the base on site to bring back
those who've left the fold to win over
the floating Waters across the country
time I think to get the advice of a
couple of political strategists and
let's start with the Democrat shall we
Sydney Blumenthal was senior advisor to
both Bill and Hillary Clinton and it is
fair to say isn't it certainly that that
not everyone wanted Biden to run again a
lot of Democrats before his announcement
were hesitant and wished him not to run
on the other hand if he did not run he
would create an Open Primary and all the
factions of the party would scramble
against each other creating openings for
the other side you know he's been very
good on his feet and he's the one who's
behind his policies there's no question
about it he's not a figurehead uh he's
in charge in terms of his policy
portfolio in terms of the first term
however whilst there have been
achievements and the recognizable even
from this side of the Atlantic do you
feel that the American public recognize
them as Joe Biden's achievements recent
polling suggests at least in terms of
his personal popularity is not
desperately strong and another
Washington Post survey that I saw not
that long ago as well suggesting that
actually in terms of what the general
public think that he has done well you
know over 60 think he's done not very
much that's a misperception he has done
an extraordinary amount uh particularly
in his first two years before the
Republicans were elected in control of
the House of Representatives there have
been enormous legislative achievements
that he's LED on the other hand
the public is uh not always aware of
them many of the uh the things that he
has done have included infrastructure uh
building in so-called red states that is
republican-led States and people are not
only unaware of it but they don't want
to be aware of it and I wonder how you
sell Joe Biden to Democrat threats who
perhaps after the amount of time that he
has served in office were perhaps
looking for a change what used to be
said about the parties that the
Republicans
um fell in line and the Democrats fell
in love so the Democrats are not in love
but they're falling in line the
Republicans are in love but they're not
falling in line so there's been a kind
of reversal character type here of the
parties so everyone in the party
understands that we're facing an
existential threat from the Republican
party and that it's likely nominee is
Donald Trump so the party is lining up
behind Biden whether or not they're in
love with him or not and they understand
that this is not an ordinary election
and that they must support Biden for not
only the party but for the fate of the
country to what extent do you think that
things like the indictment the Stormy
Daniels allegations and indeed what
happened during the the Capitol Hill
Insurrection let's call at what it was I
mean to what extent these can then be
weaponized against Donald Trump at the
general election not at this point of
course but but when we get into the
campaign proper all of these will play
out
over months of time and he will be
facing a host of legal difficulties and
at the same time uh this plays out uh
politically the more he's uh prosecuted
the more his base feels he's persecuted
in that these are politically motivated
whatever the source whatever the action
and so they cling to him and the bond
becomes stronger and stronger uh he's
now 27 points among Republicans higher
than Ron DeSantis and
before Joe Biden the way this will play
out is that there are several key swing
States and in the swing states there are
several key swing districts largely
Suburban districts of moderate voters
they're moved by among other things the
abortion issue and the Supreme Court
decision heavily but they're also moved
by Donald Trump and they are repulsed by
him
Sydney is the presidential election in
2024 is it Joe Biden's to lose of course
it's uh Joe Biden's to lose he holds the
office I think on both sides there's a
feeling and particularly on the
Democratic side that this is an
existential election about the future of
not only American democracy but of the
Western Alliance and the state of our
national security uh throughout the
world so everything is at stake in this
election thank you Sydney so what of the
grand old party Amy tarkanian is a
Republican strategist and commentator
Amy great to have you back on the
podcast so let's flip things a little
and start with Donald Trump I mean is it
an inevitability that he will be
standing in the elections next year
that's the way that it's it's actually
headed as we speak now of course in the
world of Politics as you know things
change very quickly but it does seem
that that is going to be the case
unfortunately so how do the Republicans
exploit Joe Biden's age without
appearing ageist without
essentially trying to capitalize on a
number rather than on you know the
policy achievements I think it would be
very simple I mean you can touch on the
economy for example everybody doesn't
matter what your party affiliation
feels that you know they are struggling
financially at some level you know the
price of gas the price of food it has
gone up exponentially and I think that's
an area where Republicans really could
jump on and and tout now I think that
where we're going to find ourselves in
trouble are going to be the social
issues and that's where you saw
President Biden in his announcement for
his re-election campaign really focused
on heavily and that was dealing with
anything with lgbtq issues Reproductive
Rights and health care and so
Republicans are going to have to do an
excellent job on their messaging and
getting ahead of those issues because
that's actually what helped the
Democrats succeed in the midterm it's
exactly the point I was going to make
because you know Joe Biden can look at
those results and say look you know I've
got a proven track record here look at
the midterms and look at 2020.
and he doesn't have to touch on the
economy he doesn't have to touch on
inflation or the Border because those
are the things those are the topics that
actually put a lot of the voters let's
say abortion for example a lot of people
who are pro-choice or pro-life with no
middle ground no compromise in that area
those are one-issue voters so you need
to make sure that your message is strong
and that you put enough money behind it
in order to counter those type of Voters
and be able to bring into the fold the
independence and non-partisans and
that's where I think president Trump's
really going to struggle on the Democrat
side clearly there is no clear
alternative to Joe Biden I think that in
part is one of the reasons why he's
announced that he will be standing but
on the Republican side of course you do
have Ron DeSantis I mean I'm wondering
from a Republican strategist point of
view who who offers the best opportunity
to get back get Republicans back into
the White House you know Donald Trump or
Ron DeSantis at one time I thought
Rhonda santis and now I question that
though because of a couple of moves that
he recently made and he was in his home
state of Florida and those two issues
that I think that will come back to
haunt him once he does decide to
announce his run for presidency are
going to be on gun control and on
abortion what would be the consequences
of a second Jewel Biden term do you
think well I think we're going to
continue to do a downward spiral
domestically and internationally there's
no more fear or major concern over what
goes on across the oceans you've got
North Korea out of control once again
you've got Russia you know constantly
hounding the Ukraine and then you've got
here now at home you've got people that
are coming across the border not just by
the hundreds but by the thousands I hate
to say this but I feel that it's going
to be even more Doom and Gloom but I
guess at least we know what we're
dealing with I just think that people
overall President Biden was not a
fabulous option he was in the right
place at the right time because people
were exhausted and very angry with
Donald Trump especially after the
January 6th debacle and so people are
still going to vote against him I think
in the end will it be a loss as great as
it was this last time it might be a
little bit closer I don't know that
answer but I still think he's going to
lose thanks Amy back to Mark stone for
the final thought on Biden versus Trump
round two Mark give him what happened
last time particularly those riots when
they were riots on Capitol Hill are you
actually looking forward to covering the
election next year it's going to be
incredible but it's going to be divisive
it's going to be quite depressing a lot
of American cities are in a very sad
State and the people then replicate that
sadness they are a bit desperate for for
something new something different and I
think that will translate into into
divisive politics divisive debates
um and probably a pretty divisive result
in November 24
my thanks to Amy tarkanian Sydney
Blumenthal Mark Stone and of course to
you for listening to the Sky News Daily
with me Neil Patterson this Edition was
produced by Annie Joyce with Alex Eden
our editor is Philly Bowman